jeunes gens dans le cadre de ce projet
vous deviez écrire une sorte de modèle
que vous admirez wasl miles nous dit à
qui vous avez écrit on devine cents le
dictateur donc vous avez trouvé les
preuves sur leur ordinateur
elle n'avait pas d'ordinateur en général
mais alors comment vous avez su que
c'était des traîtres non on va vous avez
dit en général
j'admire son style cher tatiana tes
lettres sont une respiration bienvenue
au milieu de mes vicissitudes
il ya une faction rebelle qui veut me
décapité je ne peux faire confiance à
personne je peux trop m'identifier à ça
ma mère se tape son gros dégâts patron
ou lycées ya un groupe de plastique qui
font la loi elles se font appeler les
soupçons et le mec qui me plaît
s'intéresse plus à jésus je te demande
pardon je sais pas pourquoi j'ai fait ça
[Musique]
des fois j'ai l'impression vous êtes le
seul coup
retrouvez plus petit que je l'avais
imaginé vous vous êtes plus jeune je
vais attendre ici
mais il faut envie d'exister
ah ça c'est moi ce taux plein ne tolère
pas j'avais prévu de parler vie c'est
pas un pédophile pervers c'est un
dictateur cet homme est un réfugié
politique il est inoffensif
c'est un petit moment horrible mon prof
de sciences sociales annoncées mais la
guerre de noyades avec du lait les
excuses je suis trop tu as du pouvoir
mais tu ne sais pas comment l'exercer
c'est facile pour vous dire ça une
rebelle ne va jamais capitulé les
rebelles rejettent en quand ce sera le
moment déstabilise le pouvoir des shows
xi par des actions décisives
les strings apparents sont empreintes du
passé il faut avoir le courage de faire
c'est en croire même si ça fait souffrir
les personnes que l'on aime
c'est de la maison les mains en l'air je
suis fier de toi pourquoi tu es devenu
une vraie rebelle
ah ah
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]